there is a new iPhone coming and it's
going to be announced by Apple in just a
couple days on September 9th and my
inside sources yahoo.com tell me that
it's going to be released the 4.7 inch
will be released on September 19th don't
quote me on that but that's what they're
telling me now we can go to the wide
shot because we all have our you guys
even painted we're on blended Isis
killed the 5.5 yeah okay so we've all
got these things so we fully admit it we
have three iPhone people here I've got
an iPad I've got a MacBook which I
knocked the glass of water on this week
and then my blow-dried and which ended
up melting the keyboard but I still have
a MacBook you got a MacBook I know use
Mac since 1984 all right so you're in it
sign on early Chad you have a MacBook or
an apple or you got a PC what I am a Mac
guy I've okay spent millions of dollars
on Apple suppository so you have the the
fax we have all fest up we're in it
we're in ass within it with the Apple
products now I want to show you there's
a couple leaked images of the iPhone 6
so let's just take a look real quick
it's gonna be thinner that's right it's
gonna be thinner so what you're seeing
there is the outside back of the case
let's look at the shot of the casing oh
wow thinner sexy isn't that thing sexy
look at that thing look at the bottom oh
I just can't three times look at the
front of the screen oh and apparently
that'll be sapphire glass which is very
hard to break okay so yeah Apple Apple
blah blah blah we all know it we kind of
love it we hate it so that's where I
want to start with this thing do you
guys sort of feel like slaves to Apple
cuz that is how I feel like when my
macbook broke a couple days ago I had
just been at Apple because my phone the
audio stopped working and I can only use
it on speaker and when I was in there
for that I kept thinking is this my
chance to get out but then I was like I
got a MacBook at home Dwight this
Samsung I guess I'd be but with this
yeah yeah Oh or that you can go to know
who makes computers now did L or M is
that a cup I mean I've got a new guy who
works on my apples at home and he used
to work for the NSA and he says everyone
in the government
apples basically everyone they make them
special for the government workers for
CIA everyone in the world is working on
these machines now so is this good or
bad
I'm saying that you know no I'm saying
that if you want the best OS and the
most efficient machine these things tend
to do better than the other ones and I
know for a fact that the Samsung people
in the comments right now we're gonna
blow up because every time we do some
pro Apple they go we got the other and
if you have Samsung bless you and and
have fun with it and it does all the
same things this does because this
invented it she said yeah I think we
should all fear Apple yeah I think Apple
is ultimately a George Orwellian
nightmare coming you know because then
it'll be no but the product and we keep
hearing like the product in the pipeline
we got 10 years of product you know what
let me tell everybody something Steve
Jobs is dead okay all right time to move
on people until I start seeing an i
liver and an eye eye and an eye ear and
an eye and an eye : you know everything
is avenged my balls went right over your
clay Apple will be the new Isis that's
my prediction
Apple will take over what that mean it
means that you know you're gonna be
loving this corporation that eventually
becomes so powerful it becomes a
nation-state so haven't they become
everything that they fought against cuz
the George Orwell I mean they did that
there will they of course we mean that's
that's like edie mainstream culture
takes the edge it simulates it and makes
it the mainstream that's what happens
but it's worse it's worse because and
we've talked about this you're gonna be
so locked into something like Apple that
at a certain point you can't get out
it's like the Mafia yeah get in but you
can't get it yeah yeah absolutely so so
you have to do small things to resist it
like my let my big computer die I had it
for six years which is unheard of an
Apple time I mean my dad was an early
adopter he had my dad don't you know did
Doc you know documents an email on his
computer he had the towers with all the
computing you know you can you can go to
this and the moon and back with this
tower every year he got a
one came out I don't do that I resist I
resistor is this I've had a crack in my
screen right the powers over a year no
not getting a new one not getting it
fixed screw you I'm walking around with
a crack I'm okay with my crack yeah
that's the novice that I already have
somebody waiting in line for that five
point five iPhone you know why because I
was cursed with on good clothes over
there Andre the Giant sighs folks so
doing this on this device I want it you
know if they don't release that five
point five I want to tell you I'm
driving up to Cupertino and I am
punching that guy in the dick that's
gonna make three sizes that's my image
no it's two sizes and if it's not a 5.5
somebody's getting a dick it's big just
for the visual we should know that you
have a smart car which is one of those
tiny little cars so if you were to get
the five point that I mean that your
phone would be bigger than your car
phone ride shotgun doesn't have to call
it just put it right there all right
last thought on Apple so you know
they're building this giant fortress in
Cupertino has an image it sort of looks
like the Pentagon although not not sure
it's round but it's got like that
feeling of a fortress so to your point
so or trous or that when is I mean
really
Apple has more money than the US
government they have liquid assets and
they are just churning out money money
money yes when will companies truly
surpass the government I mean have they
already like well who's the gentleman
the Eric Cantor this week where did he
go he went to Wall Street yeah no
there's no government is is not this
biggest thing at all big business has
way more power and I like I think it'll
be fun the Apple fortress will be fun
will be like a Hunger Games kind of a
thing maybe you know they have like fun
things in the middle and people be
killing each other feel like I
Thunderdome I hope in future and we just
have to play along which is why yes I
talk about this all the time but I
probably will get it because I don't
want to fall behind in whatever the
future may oh joy falling behind because
when the thumb war I can't wait that'll
be five point five